all right denim thank you so much for
being here today with me oh thank you
for having me yeah so I guess to start
because you have such an insane career
that's taken a bunch of different levels
and ways tell me about why you wanted to
get into the entertainment industry in
the first place uh I mean when I was
younger I was like five it was mainly
because it gave me an opportunity to get
out of class so they would pick you to
do these shows and then you had to go
rehearse so you would be and when I say
I had a class it was probably like 20
minutes but when you're five you might
as well have been all day right right so
I loved that and then I did a show um
what I was saying for like five six
hundred people and I just love the
response I love the energy and the
excitement all these other things and so
from then I just never wanted to not do
it so I went from doing theater to
musical theater and then doing that so
my love for it is the same as it was
when I was five amazing and I know you
you said musical theater that really
interests me because you're you're not
doing so much of that right now no no oh
what happened are you do your plans
doing it again or so okay so when I was
like 15 16 team I was like heavily into
musical theater trained as an opera
singer as well wow but one of the things
about these disciplines what I always
try to stress to people is like you
can't just like decide you want to just
do it walk away from it and then come
back and think that you're just gonna be
as great as you were before right it's a
discipline and so I at a certain point
had to pick one it was so I love musical
theater I loved Opera I loved the vocal
challenge of all of it but then there
was the opportunity also where I really
wanted to do the television and film
side and also financially for where I
was in my life it made a little bit more
sense uh because you know doing theater
it still hasn't you don't get the paid
and you don't the way that you would
want to to be able to make that big
living if you will are sustainable
living sometimes and so it made sense to
me but one day hopefully I'll be able to
do it like occasionally I still have you
know you know soundtracks in my car that
occasionally on long drives I still test
the vocals they're definitely not what
they were 10 years ago but it says okay
we're working on it yeah and the thing I
love about you too is that you're not
just like an actor or an Entertainer
you're also a businessman yeah tell me
about the founding of your your studio
yeah so Kumo Studios was founded two and
a half years ago when I came to Botswana
for the first time so I have two
partners on NK who are co-founders and
they're also local batsada uh we want to
do television and film and you know the
country of Botswana they have so much
desire for art entertainment and culture
but there wasn't necessarily a huge
market yet and they're still trying to
figure out like how do we scale this to
an international market with standards
and what that looks like and so I felt
like well this is literally what I do
for a living I have a passion for that I
love the teaching I love the building
and I love the birthing options when
you're going through the pain of
building a business so um it was just a
natural fit so yeah that's how Kumo and
Kumo Studios was born very cool and
obviously you're the most well known I
think in the US for Yellowstone yeah
um how did any of those lessons that you
learned about then you know the business
of Hollywood and your timeline set there
help you build yourself 100 it's the
only way that I'm able to do it so you
know the great thing so Yellowstone's on
the Paramount Network and when Paramount
started it didn't really have a full
identity yet it was trying to figure out
what do we do they were doing a lot of
like reality shows like reruns like Bar
Rescue and things of that nature and
they were trying to figure out what they
do and then this is how Taylor Sheridan
you know who's like the biggest
showrunner in the world now
um came with the script with Kevin
Costner in it and they kind of showed
Paramount like how you could build this
model you know get a good show get a
good one good start get a great
storyline and take a big swing it's a
western right and westerners were kind
of phased out in the U.S and I think now
because of it it's kind of revitalized
that and so coming over here I was like
okay these are some of the business
models get a good show find a flagship
find something that you're getting on
the pulse of the country and go from
there what's been the biggest challenge
you faced when when building your studio
up so I think you know for me you know I
don't know everything so I'm still
learning as well so it's like you're
building and you're learning and you're
building and you're learning but then
also just understanding that not every
single thing that you do in the US as
far as how you build something is
necessarily the best way to do it here
in Africa in every country in Africa has
a different way that they do business
that they hear business that they
receive business advice and things of
that nature so um which I think it's
actually made like a it makes for better
leadership because you don't do like a
one-size-fits all so you go to these
different places you do that so I think
for me more than anything it's been
about being kind of just more of the
educational side of it how does the
business of entertainment make money how
do you scale it up and so I've been
learning it myself and now through my
learning and through my education it's
helped me be able to communicate more
effectively interesting so do you see
your studio so just being Botswana or do
you have plans to expand throughout the
continent and maybe Global yeah so where
our goal is definitely so our base will
always be here in Botswana but we're
definitely we're all over the continent
like we do Kubo Masters where we do
capacity building uh where we teach
about the business of entertainment so
we teach about all the things I was just
talking about right because you can't
just say like oh we want to do
television and film but you're not also
cultivating the Next Generation right to
be able to come into that so we're going
to you know we're in Zambia we're doing
some things in South Africa we'll be in
Tanzania we'll be in Kenya we'll be in
Namibia and so we'll kind of see what
this model you know and then we'll
eventually we'll we'll see where it
takes us has it been hard to find
funding or things to propel this forward
in any type of VC funding or what's your
experience so yeah it is a little bit
challenging only because it's a model
where people don't really think like
Africa entertainment Studios what does
that look like and unless it's kind of
like a Netflix or an Amazon or a Hulu
for a lot of people it's like it doesn't
really make any sense right like denim
is not Disney right so it's not like an
odd automatic let's go and do it so a
lot of the stuff that we've been doing
especially the first year as the
entrepreneurs like you just sell funds
right and you just you figure it out and
then as you start to do that it becomes
easier when you're actually going to get
the venture capitalist funding and
things of that nature because they've
seen oh you guys like really believe in
it it's not like you just had an idea
brought it to us want us to take all the
risk it's like oh you've been doing this
for a while you're taking some massive
swings here if that's the case and
you're here and I think that's something
that's important for me was I didn't
want to do it until I knew I could be
here for most of the time because I
don't like going and saying hey let's do
a partnership and then you're not in the
country and I'm not in the country and
now I'm having somebody that's not as
engaged running it so now we're at a
place where I can be here most of the
year
um outside of doing Yellowstone and so
now we're have a better opportunity to
take some bigger swings that makes sense
yeah so a little bit of a fun question
for you yes maybe thinkers so what do
you wish that you had known about the
entertainment industry when you were
first starting out that you know now
that so I say this thing uh in our Kuma
Masters that your passion is going to
make you poor
um I wish that I had knew more about the
business side of it more than just be
passionate about it just be excited to
get up and go do the job right or go do
the art and I think sometimes in the
entertainment industry we get so caught
up in just wanting to be like the artist
but the artist also needs to have like
lawyers and accountants and understand
like Investments and things of that
nature and scalability as well like
you're these small businesses and I
think so more than anything I wish I
would have known that like the passion
is great because it's kind of like a
given circumstance that you need to have
to even want to get into this right but
you really got to know the business and
how to do that and then the passion will
kind of Drive everything else so with
that being said what advice what
business advice would you give to young
entrepreneurs who are who are in the
same spot you were in so I would say
more than anything you would make sure
that you don't have an ego and don't be
in the business of entitlement like no
one is going to just give you something
just because you've decided that you
have a good idea there's a lot of great
ideas a lot of good ideas not every good
or great idea it means it's going to get
funded so you have to have that real
belief in yourself that this is
something that you really feel like
you're going to do everything that you
need to do to make sure this gets done I
say this like by all moral means
necessary just win right so make sure
that you're not in the business of
entitlement make sure you don't have an
ego and be open to Partnerships right
would you rather have 50 of something or
100 of nothing right and then from there
as your life goes on then you can kind
of dictate what that percentage looks
like makes a lot of sense and one last
question for you uh what are your
biggest goals for this upcoming year and
are there any announcements or anything
exciting in the pipeline you could tell
us about so I mean we're going to be
doing a couple new shows here um here in
Botswana where I'm really excited about
scaling up our Kumo Masters which is
like I said it's our it's our capacity
building program that we'll be doing all
over the continent to be able to help
governments as well as other
entrepreneurs in entertainment be able
to kind of get more people that
understand the technicalities of the
business so I'm really excited about
that obviously we'll be doing going back
soon to do the back half of season five
for Yellowstone uh so there's a couple
other ones I have to wait until contract
assignment before I can announce but I'm
really looking forward to this year just
being bigger than the last one awesome
well thank you so much for being here
thank you